when i was in grade six i discovered  ebay i was like whoa you can get really  cheap things  i was like dad like get a load of ebay  like this is awesome he went on ebay and  he started buying soviet art because you  couldn't get art out of the soviet union  when it was the soviet union and dad was  like okay i'm gonna snatch up like all  the art i possibly can because this is  gonna be worth a bunch in the future and  our house ended up completely filled  with art which drove my mom crazy  at one point we counted 104 paintings so  i think it first occurred to me when i  went over to other people's houses and i  was like we had 37 different paint  colors on the walls there were paintings  on the ceiling i came home from  university one time i was lying in bed  and a painting of lenin fell on  i think going to other people's houses  and then seeing what it looked like and  being like this is plain that's kind of  weird